thanks everybody for joining the
uh the zoom call uh today we'll be
talking about how to serve what models
in production uh particularly in uh the
context of the by torch infant server
called torch surf
so today's agenda will be uh we'll be
talking about a little um a little about
the use cases for machine learning that
we've seen at walmart
we'll review some deep learning concepts
there'll be a hands-on session after
that
where we have a collab notebook out and
uh
we'll do some hands-on work with there
there will also be another hands-on
session after that we'll also talk about
a little uh optimizing the model for
production uh supposed training steps uh
pruning model distillations that kind of
stuff we'll do a hands-on on that as
well uh after a short break we'll do
another hands-on on how to deploy the
model and at the end you'll see a live
session and you should be able to run
live instruments
on your torch server
so once again my name is adway and we
have nitin on the call we're both
machine learning and software engineers
uh at walmart we work on the search team
uh so a lot of the problems we we work
with are search rankings search
relevance and personalization kind of
problems
so the use cases that we see at walmart
search for machine learning some of them
are spell check uh type ahead
microservices
guided navigation
uh item and skew understanding so item
and skew understanding is usually
an async task we have models running uh
24 7 pretty much that
understand
how better to
decipher
skews and skew attributes
and then on the
on the runtime side we have query
understanding models which are live and
at runtime with the user inputs a search
query given a product gender attributes
uh age size
uh these models try and understand these
attributes semantically much better and
then match them on the skew side to
better yield relevant search results for
the search engine
personalized ranking is another use case
that we see at walmart search
so here you see uh the use cases in
action on the left you can see type
ahead uh given a query uh
we're giving the user we're giving the
customer some
uh type of head suggestions on what the
in there or to better uh narrow down on
what the intent of the of the customer
is going to be on the right you see
guided navigation builds
these have been populated given our deep
learning models so customers usually
that start off with a query such as milk
uh through the customer journey end up
at a certain other uh product and a skew
this could be almond milk this could be
lactose free milk or chocolate milk and
then we extract these attributes from
the end destination at where the
customer ended up and then that's how
the model learns
uh for future users where uh a query is
very broad and how to narrow down the
the intent of the customer
um so again another example so this is
uh from our product type classification
models so given a query of nike men's
shoes uh we extract the brand as nike uh
gender attributes of men
and uh our prototype classifiers
ascribe a confidence score to each of
the product types athletic shoes here
has 99 percent
uh casual and dress shoes could be
another product type you know it's a
scribed a confidence score of 55 percent
um on the skew side it maps it on to
whatever the relevant uh
skus it deems appropriate so here you
can see another skew nike black white
shoe size and seven and a half uh as a
relevant search result
so what are the requirements
and um
and what was the motivation behind uh
our torts of uh discovery uh to serve
models of production so currently all
our models most of our models are in
tensorflow and uh on x back-ends
and they are served in a java native
environment so these are spring boot uh
services usually
and they load the models in memory and
then they're running in a kubernetes
cloud-based environment
we want to search larger models like
bert
and this is where uh dot serve comes in
dot serve also has a lot of other
advantages which we will cover on later
in the in the presentation uh we work
with strict slas in production we have
strict requirements as to what latency
should be and what the throughput
requirements are going to be uh since
most of our microservices operate
at an slav under 40 milliseconds
we see that torch serve on a gpu based
environment since dotso provides a lot
of support for gpu and cuda
optimizations
seems to yield really good results
so this will be the repo that we will be
using uh during the hands-on session
i'll cover this later on
um so for the hands-on session we have a
data set
that
was published by uc berkeley and it's
got products from amazon uh so this is
what the skus look like the skews have
information on the brands the item ids
item names product types
uh this is what the data set looks like
and we'll be using this to run live
influence
on a torch server
um at the end of the hands-on session
you should be able to make a simple rest
call to the torch server and uh the
prototype classifier that is hosted on
the torch server should yield uh product
types with confidence scores as shown
here so given your query of verbal d
here it shows d as uh it it
it deems t to be the most appropriate
prototype with a 72 percent
uh
confidence cover
so let's review some deep learning
concepts before we get into the hands-on
session
uh so where were text-based models for
these kind of use cases before report
and transform models came by so we had
word embedding models and we had word 2x
we had glove we had elmo
and these kind of models
the problem with most of these models
was that they were not most of them were
not bi-directional to start with some
lstms long short-term memory models were
bi-directional but they were not deeply
bi-directional so i'll give an example
so let's say um
let's let's let's take two sequences of
of two separate sequences of words uh
riverbank and bank deposit both of them
have uh the word bank common but uh
if the tri if the if the
model goes left to right or right to
left the context of the word is very
different
of the word bank is very different in
both the sequences of the word of the in
both the sequences
uh so this is an example where these
models fell short since they were not
deeply bi-directional they would lose
the context uh
of the of the world uh even even even
shallow bi-directional models such as
bi-directional lcms uh since they went
left to right learned the context left
to right and the right to left
separately and then ended up
concatenating them the deep um
meaning the deep semantic meaning of the
word was lost
uh this is when transformed models came
by to alleviate some of these issues uh
on the left you can see
a typical
lstm
model and
how it works
so some use cases where
trans uh where transform models came by
and
went on to
help us give birth
so some use cases where these models
were used machine translation question
answering sentiment analysis
um as i mentioned in the previous slide
no we did not have contextualized
embeddings that's something but solved
uh
salt uh salt for us this was the first
truly deep bi-directional model
in a transform model if you stack up all
the encoding layers you get a port model
since this was a general language model
that was trained on tasks such as master
word prediction and next sentence
prediction
uh
in a semi supervised manner it could be
trained on a much larger corpus of of
words
tokenizer also sought for out of
vocabulary words um
something that really helps let's say
you have a spelling mistake or something
in that case uh
you're not you're not you don't have a
word in the vocabulary and
uh
but
alleviates that issue for you again
uh so again we stack the in transformers
uh encoding layers and you get a bird
model and uh
it's on the left you can see a word
model in
action uh so bird has different
architectures uh we see uh given the
bird recipe we have multiple versions of
the model if we tune the number of
attention heads and the hidden size of
the models
so here you we have a small table with
berta and e mini small and medium these
are smaller than both large and
bird-based models
um and
they've been uh they're we see a lot the
last two columns show uh the glue scores
for
two of the relevant tasks that we deemed
to our use case uh so sst is a stanford
sentiment uh tree bank uh this is a data
set and then qqp is a quora question
pairs and you can see that uh you can
see how
the
the
models perform uh on these on these uh
glue tasks
and how they progress when once they go
we go from uh lower uh layers of
complexity to higher
uh so by lstms and bert's uh word we
have uh we have some we ran some
predictions for the query betting for
twin xl mattresses
uh you can see the the confidence scores
we got a pretty good f1 score
improvement f1 is a metric
that
combines the relevance in the recall of
a search engine
and you can see the improvement went
from 0.75 to 0.91
so that was a pretty big improvement
again uh to to showcase the motivation
behind port and and uh
how much word helped when it came by
um i'll be handing over the talk now to
my colleague nathan he's going to run
through an uh hands-on session
then take it all
thanks everyone thanks avi um so
um as you guys know we have this slack
channel serving by torch models
where again we have shared
the repo and slides but i also shared it
on
zoom chat
if you have it
but again the link is just
bitly slash pytorch workshop 2021 i'll
just share it again in the zoom chat
so um
so this is the setup portion so you know
if you face issues while you know
setting this up on your end
and especially if you're interested in
running the notebooks together you know
please
please do
raise any issues in the zoom chat so
so this is our repo
if you scroll down a little bit so we
have several notebooks
um but let's just click this link here
opening collab so this is just a starter
notebook that we'll have
so if you click it
the content of the notebook is not that
important it's just like some set of
pieces
so um just click uh run time run all and
uh for for our workshop
since we won't actually be doing
training we'll mainly be focusing on
inference so you don't need to have like
a gpu runtime as such and this default
cpu runtime is sufficient so just click
runtime run all
and the steps might take about like
three minutes or so
basically like since we have um
several notebooks that we want to go
over basically
inside the collab runtime we're just
cloning the repo
uh cloning the data set that we talked
about cloning a model that we trained on
the specific data set
uh installing the requirements that we
need
and then basically
installing like a
vs code session so we can basically
interact with the collab environment a
little bit more interactively
so
this again may take three minutes um you
know if you face issues or you know
please do share in the zoom chat
um also um feel free to ask any
questions about the earliest section too
um but basically
uh just to summarize you know uh
in production we started with a bio sdm
model and you know we were interested in
boot and as you saw from the f1 score
that's actually
our actual production f1 score on our
eval data set so that was a huge bump
and definitely be interested in pushing
this into production
and okay so this again might take two or
three minutes or so so um
if you want to follow along feel free to
run run this we also have in the repo
like the already pre-executed notebooks
so you know if you just want to read it
also that's fine too
so basically we are using vs code again
so we can get access to the internal
runtime so you should see a link here
code server can be accessed uh using
this ngrok tunnel so just click on this
and then uh
it'll open like vs code
um and um
right now it's not pointed to the folder
where cool lab normally runs so
basically if you just click open folder
and navigate to content
and then you'll basically see the github
repo and all the artifacts downloaded
and such again these instructions are
shared
in the readme of the repo
but
i'm also open to taking any questions
uh sorry
questions shares okay am i sharing the
wrong slide oops sorry let me
let me stop sharing in
sorry share screen um
oh apologies for that um can you see my
screen um so
uh this was the repo um
the link to it was bitly pytoch workshop
2021 uh it's also shared
in the slack channel uh serving pi touch
models in production
and in the repo there is the open in
collab button that you see that will
show a
starter
notebook just click run time run all
and
once it's basically done
it will basically
show you this link that you can open
and once you have this link open you
have a vs code session just click on
open folder and navigate to slash
content
um
if maybe like people in like
zoom can just share like with an emoji
like if you are
like if you're having any issues or such
or if everything's good maybe like a
thumbs
up okay cool i see one so js seems good
um so again um while people are setting
up i will maybe just go over like one of
the notebooks again there are lots of
notebooks that we will go over together
but let's just
go over the first notebook
so the first notebook that we will be
reviewing is just kind of getting
familiar with you know the libraries in
the hugging phase ecosystem and the
python ecosystem
so let's just wait for this notebook to
open a bit
it's taking some time
let's click on it again
so you may see this thing do you want to
trust this notebook
you know it's fine to trust it or again
you can see the rendered notebook on
github
so
um let me just duplicate these um
and let me just duplicate the notebook
so we can just compare the results so
uh since we are not using a gpu runtime
uh the
the numbers that you see here will
basically be running on a very limited
um will be running on a very limited
machine like so in fact if we just uh
look at this collab environment
uh so this is only a two core machine
with like 13 gigs so
this is a pretty uh not powerful machine
so just keep in mind some of the numbers
that we see inside this notebook
and that's why it's different from
the numbers in the
committed repo
so let me just clear all the outputs in
the notebook and let's just run this so
in this notebook what we'll be going
over is how to use the hugging phase
like how to load a model that was
trained with hugging faces library both
the model and tokenizer you know how to
use hugging faces data set library and
how to see
and see how to use in how to run
inference on this model so
uh transformers is a library from
hugging face that basically
has where you can load a pre-trained
model uh where you can even train your
own model
uh torch is you know uh pythog from
facebook
um
torchwiz is just a library to visualize
the network
datasets is a library from hugging phase
to
uh to perform like fast operations on
data sets to create data sets to load
your own data sets
so like the first thing that we're going
to do is to load the
uh model so
inside the
model directory here distilled bird
cased uh we have some model artifacts we
have the pytorch artifact we have some
config files that hugging face uses to
load we have the tokenizer information
that hugging face needs and we have the
actual vocab
so
luckily hugging face makes it simple to
load all these things just call
transformers dot auto model for sequence
classification since our task is
a
multi-class multi-class classification
problem
so let's look at the model object so the
model that we trained is a distilled
bird model so we have about like six
transformer blocks in this model
um which has which does several things
and we have a classifier layer so
uh in this case the for this data set we
only uh we only have 31 classes and the
classes
relate to like product types that you
might see like a bed sheets uh
furniture electronics things like that
so
one nice thing about hugging face is
that inside the model object you can
basically give a map where you have the
numeric ids mapped to like a string
label so you don't need to necessarily
have a separate artifact
so the next thing is let's load the
tokenizer again hugging face makes it
very simple so just call transformers
dot auto tokenizer from pre-trained and
you basically give a directory where it
is in in this case since we have the
tokenizer config
in the same directory as a model we just
load it and then you know we see if the
gpu is available
or not in this case since we are
basically using the
uh a cpu environment this will be a cpu
environment so now let's just see you
know how to make inference on a simple
query right so here's our query like
let's say cheap professional menus
uh then we call the tokenizer dot encode
plus
where we basically give the query we
tell it that we want pi torch tensors we
want to add to the maximum light which i
believe is 5 12 and if this query was
super long we will truncate it too so in
this case
we have about like what is the six
tokens and the rest are zeros because
there's no mapping so these are the
uh token ids from the words
and we have the attention mask here
which just basically in our case just
maps to
the tokens that we have
so this is one way to call the model you
just call model and you just pass in the
dictionary of both inputs
and here you get the logits from the
model
and you know typical pi torch or even
tensorflow what you want to do is to
apply soft max on this output
get the top predictions you know convert
to probability
and get the class labels
so here are the numeric labels
there's a nice helper function that by
torch has which basically
you can map these things to the labels
in this case since it was like cheap
professional men's shoes we see like
shoes was the product type that best
matches the high confidence
so that's basically how you use a phi
torch model whether it's a bird model or
a regular bioscheme
and if you want a visual representation
of what the model looks like we can use
this great library torturous
and you know we see we have the
uh input ids uh the attentions we see
the weights and this is a very big
very big graph of the model of all the
steps inside which is very hard to
navigate but yeah um
so if you want to if you're curious to
look at specific layers and operations
but for our case uh
that's sufficient so
let's see for the next part of the
notebook you know if you want like an
interactive way to interact with the
model we just have like a simple eye
python widget where you know you can
enter the query
and see the output of the model so you
just want to play of course you can just
go in about cell and change it
[Music]
you know we covered how to
uh load a trained model how to load a
trained tokenizer and how to do a
prediction but maybe in uh in your use
case you might want to run it on a batch
of input right so in our case here we
have a data set that we saved using
hugging faces data set library
we're just going to load it so in our
data set as we showed you know we had
the brand we have the item id
item title um in this case since this is
a pure nlp problem we only care about
the item title which is item name and we
both have and we have a train test and
validation split
so um this is just a usage of hugging
faces tokenizer library where we
basically
for
for all these folds the test the
training and the validation we're going
to apply this function where we
basically tokenize the
uh text value inside there and we padded
to the max length and we truncate it
and
since again this is running on a cpu it
might take some time
so this finished probably on the test
fold
and we still have the train and
validation so we see like for about um
um like it is an extensive model right
it takes about 11 seconds uh
to run a distilled bird model which is
one of the smaller models we'll be
covering today
so after we apply this operation we will
see we should see um like the input ids
and the tension mask again we this is a
dictionary that we fed on a single
prediction so here we have these are we
can think of this as a pandas data frame
that basically have these fields
so uh since we're not running on a gpu
let's just take the first 20 uh outputs
of this
and um
we can then basically
uh so now there are several ways we can
do a batch prediction on this full data
set right so if you can use the hugging
face ecosystem you know there's the
transformers.trainer object which is the
same object that you might have used for
training
and you can just basically call
trainer.predict and you pass like the
hugging face data set
and it will automatically you know use
all the gpus in a very efficient manner
and the hugging phase dataset library
has
all the popular metrics that you might
have used you know accuracy f1 precision
basically you can load this object
and then you can
uh
you can give it uh your actual
predictions and the reference
predictions and it will compute the
accuracy in this case you know since we
don't have a gpu we only took the top
20. so the accuracy
number is not that meaningful
so you know that's basically how you
might call
the predictions on a batch if you want
to like
feed uh if you you can also use you know
like the
thunder method and basically pass like
input ids and attention mask but what
you need to do is you need to be careful
that
the tensors once it's loaded and edge
model also fits all in like memory
uh so that's basically it um i think
this is all i wanted to cover for this
notebook
um hopefully you guys got a flavor of
how to
how to load a model and how to run
inference on it
other notebook we wanted to cover today
and we're not going to run this because
it does take some time is to
um is to look at you know the difference
the diff the timing information
for the different uh bird models and
bird architectures
so as avi mentioned you know like
there's bird base bird lodge and then
there's also the distilled version of
these models and we'll cover what
distillation is a bit later
so
the numbers again here are running on so
i'm not going to run this notebook but
this notebook was run on a 16 core
machine with the nvidia t4 gpu
so
here again we're using the great hugging
face transformers library to load a
pre-trained earth large uncased model
and what i want to highlight is the time
it takes
so
like on a cpu
this model takes about eight forty seven
milliseconds on a single uh input batch
uh back size of one
um on a gpu it goes to 300 milliseconds
so
it's still
not within our sla right so it's pretty
high so now if you take like a smaller
model which i think um if bird base has
12 attention sets this is six
so birth base uh we see that the cpu
inference took 251 milliseconds and
uh if you run it on a d4 gpu it takes
about 45 milliseconds
so um
we see some improvement and like we're
getting closer for bird base but it's
still a little bit on a large end
now if we use a distilled bird model we
see that we go from 125 milliseconds on
the cpu and 26 milliseconds on the
gpu and this is without any
optimizations so now we're getting a
little bit closer to kind of the sla
that we need to meet
so um you know these are the two
notebooks hopefully you guys were able
to
uh have everything set up and follow
along with the notebook and
uh you know if you uh if you got
if you weren't able to follow you know
that's fine we have two other notebooks
that um
that you don't need to have completed
running this notebook
so
let me go back to the slides uh are
there any questions before i go to next
so
okay i think hopefully everyone is good
um
hopefully everyone is set up if i could
just see like maybe like uh an emoji
just to see if like everyone is able to
follow along before we go to the next
section
let's see one um hopefully
hopefully everything is good um you know
again feel free to post on
the zoom chat
if any issues
so
let me just go to this
hopefully you can see my screen so
okay so we covered two notebooks we saw
you know how
how expensive some of these bird models
can be and we saw like the distilled
bird model uh
the sla on gpu is kind of probably
within our range
so now let's look into like some model
optimization techniques that we could do
to further improve the performance
so the first technique that we're going
to look at is quantization
so you know when we trained our model we
use 32-bit precision
but you know for inference you really
need such a high precision you know most
of the time we could probably convey the
same information with probably a lower
precision 16 bits and maybe eight bits
eight bit ins and you may see a drop in
accuracy but it may be used it may still
be useful for your use case especially
considering the memory and computation
speed up that you might see
so on most hardwares in eight
computations is much faster
um
probably like on a factor of 2x to 4x
compared to
a floating point 32-bit position
and most of the time the depending on
your problem and data set
like the drop in accuracy from
quantization may not be much
so on the right hand side you see an
image so basically you know if you're
using 32-bit precision you might have
like a large range
where you might have like a max and min
and you can see values continuous values
in that range
and you know
maybe all your values that you actually
see for your model like for the weights
or activations might not be within that
range
so what you can do is you know you can
quantize it and you know with things
like rounding clipping and finding the
right mapping function for your layer
you can probably create like a graph
that looks like below and
it may work for your use case it may
capture enough
knowledge that might be needed
so in pytoch we have three different
types of
quantization all the quantizations that
we're going to cover are going to
quantize the weights but there's some
other differences we very differ
so
the first one we're going to cover is
dynamic quantization so as i mentioned
all the weights are quantized uh in
whichever strategy that we're going to
cover
but where dynamic quantization
uh differs is it doesn't quantize the
activations
so
the activations are quantized
dynamically on the fly so
you feed your tensor you multiply by the
weights you get your activations the
actuations are converted to ins then
it's multiplied with the next operation
and then it's converted back into floats
so you don't really see any memory
improvement but you do see
a speed up because you're doing the
large matrix multiplications in in eight
math
um
yeah so let's see how to use dynamic
quantization now pytorch makes it very
simple so here you know if you have your
32-bit float model you can call
torch.quantization quantize dynamic pass
in your model you pass it which a list
of layers that you want to pass
at quantize and you pass uh
what type you wanted it is 16-bit or
indeed
so that was technique one which is the
most simple and which is also the
recommended technique for like
transformer models like both
the second technique
is static quantization
so
so static quantization
uh here the weights and activations are
both quantized
um so in order for the activations to be
quantized there needs to be a
calibration data that needs to be
provided
and one of the beauty beautiful things
about this is you know since the
activations are also quantized like you
don't have this like uh constant
conversion from floats to ins so
inference is much faster in this mode
the other thing to think about is you
know if you know you're going to
quantize the model you might as well
look into something called quantization
of their training
basically uh what you can do is like you
know when you define the training laws
for your
model you can tell it to consider what
the uh you can also tell it to consider
the quantization error loss so basically
when the model is being trained
it will find the best architecture best
weights that also minimizes the
quantization error and this method leads
to best accuracy
so let's look into how these three
different techniques that we just
covered you know
how they like what are the improvements
they may bring
so the first result that we have uh
first row is for both
we see that for if you use 32-bit
precision we get about a 90 accuracy but
if we use 8 precision we dropped by
0.05 percent
um but if you look at the speed up we we
get a 1.8 x speed up and again this is
not on a gpu this is on a cpu so from we
went all the way from 581 milliseconds
to 313 milliseconds
which is a pretty great speed up
for if you look at the cv model resin at
50
we see a drop of one percent in accuracy
using static uh static quantization
but we do see like a 2x speed up so for
a one percent
drop in accuracy a 2x speed up
especially in production is a great use
case
now for the final model mobile net v2
we see um so this model it does suffer a
little bit from quantization so
when we use quantization of air training
we only see a 0.3 drop in accuracy
but uh the last row we're running on a
samsung s9 so which is a phone here so
we're seeing a 5.7 x percent speed up so
obviously on phones they don't have the
compute power of uh like your server
desktop so floating point operations are
even slower
so that's why you see such a big
improvement
so you know we covered quantization the
next uh optimization technique that
we're going to cover is distillation
you know so for distillation we have
like large models like bird
and
you know this model is great it has a
very great
lot it has a very large knowledge
capacity then you know like your simple
models like biostm
but you know maybe for your problem you
don't really need all that learning
capacity right so
uh
so what you know what would be great if
you know your smaller optimal model if
you can tell it to maybe mimic
what the larger model is learning for
your problem
so basically what you're going to do is
you know you're going to take your birth
model
make it act as a teacher model
and then you're going to take your
smaller you know let's say biology model
you're going to tell it to be a student
you're going to tell it to basically try
to
mimic the
loss and prediction that the teacher
network is giving for your data set and
the goal is like you know because the
your student network is maybe small it
might not be able to explore the large
uh
hyper parameter space um
but by having by having the teacher
network uh already learned and doing
well on the problem you're helping the
student network kind of reach
converge in a reach a better accuracy
so let's see you know what is the effect
of distillation in practice
so if you take a look at the second row
so here we have a bird-based model which
has a 93 on the stanford sentiment
analysis data set
and then if you look at the last row
which is the biologium
so
the biostem model by default only has 86
accuracy
so if we do distillation from what we
talked about before we go all the way to
90.7
which is a great uh improvement from
and the great thing is also you're using
the bios team right which is uh pretty
uh infant sufficient but now you're able
to increase its accuracy
so we covered quantization we covered
distillation let's come let's look into
the last optimization that we'll be
covering today
so
the last thing is the eager mode and
script mode so one of the many reasons
why pytorch became very popular is
the fact that it was very interactive it
was easy to prototype and debug
what powers this is because pytorch by
default runs in eager execution mode so
eager execution mode allows us to get
immediate feedback from our python
interpreter
um you know you can you have your layers
you can pass in your tensor and you get
feedback from that
without like creating the graph
you can use any of the libraries in the
python ecosystem
but you know this
reliance on the python process makes it
a little bit slow for
inference in production
so uh
so what you can do is you know once
you're done training you can explore
using script mode
so in script mode what you basically do
is you take your model that was trained
on each execution mode uh you and then
you create an optimized graph from it
and the beauty of this mode is you know
you're not tied to the python process
anymore you you only need you only
need to rely on a c plus runtime so if
there are other languages that your
production models are being served in as
long as they have
uh their language bindings to the c plus
plus runtime for
uh lib torch then you can basically use
uh python in your environment
the other thing to note is
when you use script mode you're
technically not using python you're
using torch script so torch script is an
optimized like representation of a
pytorch model
so it doesn't really support all the
operations that you might be able to
use
in regular pytorch
and it also doesn't really support like
python data structures
but the speeder from script mode is
is significantly significant so you
might want to consider using it so let's
see how we can convert the model from
eager execution to script mode
and um
in this case we'll be using uh pi totals
just in time compilation
so so pi torch has the just in time
compiler and it supports two mode
tracing mode and script mode
so
the tracing mode supports um
like it's the most simplest to use you
know as long as you're not using
python data structures inside your
forward method
um
it's very easy to use you just pass it a
sample input and the just in time
compiler will look at the execution
graph and create the optimal execution
graph for that
the other thing is you know
other mode is script mode so if you do
need to use a custom control flow or if
you need to use python data structures
you you're limited to script mode you do
get some of the benefits of
some speed up but it's not significant
so let's take a look at
it in practice so here is a
simple pytorch model if you notice in
the forward loop we have a if else block
so because there's this python
conditional we can't use the trace mode
that we use so we had to use script mode
so
um
yep this is again very simple for python
to run it and you just call model.save
and now you have your just in time
compiled model running in script mode
so let's see how much improvement we got
from this approach
so
um we have two columns here the cpu
inference time and the gpu inference
time
so just that one line you know
doing the uh tote chitta tracer tote
so we went from 1.3 seconds all the way
down to 768 milliseconds so 42
improvement just from that one small
change
on the gpu we saw a slightly smaller
improvement but it's still significant i
would say
so we looked into three techniques right
we looked into quantization we looked
into uh distillation and we looked into
like converting a trace mode
all these
approaches that we talked about is uh we
applied it to our model in production
so
now we're about to go to the next um
lab where we basically just kind of work
through
uh where we look through some of these
approaches that we talked about so
um
i'm open to taking any questions that we
have and on this
okay so i see one question from edwin uh
is the training time the same or more
with quantization of their training as
it would be
without any quantization so from what we
saw like um
the time was not really significant
because it's just like an additional
metric that it is taking um
[Music]
yep uh cool are there any other
questions
cool um
cool okay so let's um let's uh get into
workshop two um
so sorry so again here's the link the
bitly link to the repo hopefully
hopefully you all have it
um
and you know we just did this first step
to open the co lab environment hopefully
you're all set there
and
uh once you have your vs code
environment um
we will see this notebook
a tree optimizing model so again i'm
just going to duplicate this in case we
want to
look at the previous run
see
me close this and try opening this again
so let me click trust this notebook
so in this notebook what we're going to
do is again you know the steps that we
did before about you know loading the
artifact loading the model
what we're going to do is quantize the
model
and then
use torch script to
to convert the model to script mode
so
let me clear
all this cells
and it's just going to
run over some of the initial cells
because they're just basically loading
the model and artifact which is which we
covered last time
okay so the heart of the notebook will
be this section like optimizing
quantizing the model
and as we discussed you know python
supports stream modes in this case
dynamic quantization is sufficient for
our case
so
i'm just going to wait for it to run a
little bit
uh maybe while it was i'll just go over
some of the cells so as we saw in the
slides you know
we can just call doorstop quantization
dot quantized dynamic you just pass in
your model and you pass switch layers
for this case for the bird model i think
it's sufficient for the linear layer
um to give us enough improvement for our
case
and um let's see how we'll be doing with
the earlier steps of running okay see we
loaded here okay great so
i'm just going to put the model to the
cpu although there's only the cpu in
this run time since we're not using the
gpu
so let's apply quantization in this
model
so
let's see how much um
space
we
we gained from doing this quantization
so if you just look at the file size you
know we went from 267 to 138 megabytes
uh you might expect a little bit you
know larger things since we're going all
the way from 32 bit to eight bit but i
touch
uses some other data structures to kind
of keep track of uh some information so
that's why we you don't see quite the
uh storage space but um
you'll definitely see the inference time
improvement
so let's try to you know run a benchmark
on the original model the 32-bit model
and the quantized model
so since i don't have a gpu like just in
the evaluation loop we just return if a
gpu is used so
but if you are if you are able to get a
gpu you know feel free to run this in
that environment
so let's see how much improvement
we get we got from doing this
quantization
so here we are uh again this is the
32-bit model and this is the
um
sorry um i should have run this cell so
okay so this is the 32-bit model
uh running for a couple of iterations
and then this is the quantized model so
let me just run this
so we saw like from a single iteration
and maybe it might need some warm up it
took um some time so here let's see it's
saying it took 878 milliseconds and
again this is not a very powerful
machine but still it is a little bit
high right
um
so let's see how much time we got from
just doing this small quantization
improvement
so i realized i put the timing a little
bit different
maybe while this is running okay so six
seventy six eighteen milliseconds right
unfortunately right now like pytorch
doesn't support
dynamic quantization
um with uh cuda kernels so
we don't have this measurement but if we
look at the improvement that we got
again this number here is on a slightly
different and more powerful machine but
if you look
uh on that benchmark we got 116
milliseconds for the 32-bit model when
we did quantization we went to 83
and
on a gpu we were getting 17 in this run
and one thing to keep in mind is like um
you know like uh it depends also like on
how many threads you know like the
underlying c plus library sees that it
can use so here like it looks like it's
only seeing like one tread
uh with a concurrency of two and on the
other environment
uh that we ran you know we have 16 cores
so that's why like the numbers that you
saw here are maybe not as significant as
you saw on the slide spreads running on
it clearly you know on a purely single
threaded machine
so we covered quantization now let's
look at
um the other mode which is basically
tracing the model to create to make it
run on a optimized executed graph
so
one thing you need to do is if you're
using hugging face is you need to pass
this flag towards script equals true
when you load the model
and this basically
um like kind of decouple some of the
layers that
are kind of how hugging face has the
model architected which kind of torch
script doesn't really like um
you can find details like on the docks
here but for now we can just pass this
flag and hugging face kind of decouples
the embedding and encoder layer
so we have the model and tokenizer um
again um this is this is not really
running in trace mode this is just like
some internal decoupling that hugging
face is doing
so um to actually uh use it we call
sorry we just called torch.jit.trace
you pass in the model
uh and you pass in a dummy
input so um hugging phase can sorry pi
touch can kind of look at the
a model and how the graph is executed to
create the optimal graph
yep so all right okay so um
i'm just running it so just maybe in the
interest of time let me just go to
the timing information or
let's just see
so
when we ran it on the again the slightly
powerful environment we saw that
uh we were getting 130 milliseconds for
the
original model with 32-bit precision on
cpu
after tracing it
it became 124
but once we do both quantization and
tracing it became 89 milliseconds
and um you know you can run the other
cells in a notebook but we already have
all the artifacts saved so
uh we can i'm just going to go over the
notebook towards the end
so
uh one thing you need to do like and
it's important for the model serving is
you need to create a map of your string
labels to classes
um so
uh there's this data structure which you
know hugging face already has as part of
the model um
and this is one of the things with like
when you trace the model you know like
uh torch script doesn't really support
somebody's fight on data structures so
in order to do the mapping from
um
your numeric labels to
uh string labels you need to
uh keep track of the classes uh the
friend human friendly names by yourself
um so we'll just save it in a json file
some other thing that might be useful
for
um you know later use cases you might
want to have some artifacts that are
packaged as part of your model right so
maybe you want to keep track of hey do i
need to lowercase
um do i need to tell the tokenizer to
lowercase the model you know how many
labels did i have
uh is the artifact that i'm bundling as
um as part of my deployment was it you
know traced
or is it you know just a regular 32-bit
precision
um and you know like how many how much
like do i want to get a top five top ten
so this is a deployment option that we
will cover later but basically the idea
is you can package whatever artifacts
that you need as part of your deployment
using torso that we'll cover soon
so that's basically what i wanted to
cover for this notebook and the basic
idea
was to show that you know you can you
can get pretty good improvements
um uh with doing some of these small
optimizations and again they may not
seem significant but when you are
dealing with uh millions of requests uh
like all these small things do matter
so uh this is what we had for
section two now my uh co-presenter avi
is going to show you how to take all the
optimized model and how to actually
serve it with
serve it with pie torches toaster so i'm
going to stop sharing
yeah thanks a lot melinda
okay uh so let's dive into how to deploy
the model
and the steps required so uh we had a
couple of options to deploy the pytorch
models uh pure flask or fast api was a
way to go then uh the other
machine learning frameworks have their
uh inference servers as well so
tensorflow has tensorflow serving nvidia
has come up with nvidia triton
um and then we have torso we went the
torch survey and i'll run into a couple
of
uh benefits of using torch serve
so
uh to start with torso is highly
optimized it has configurable support
for for cuda and gpu environments
and since most of the need that arose
for us was to run in a gpu environment
uh it made sense for us to go the shorts
away torso has multi model serving as
well uh so you can host multiple
versions of the same model at the same
time on the same server so that's
particularly useful if your team wants
to perform some av testing
you can run traffic you can split
traffic between both the versions of
those of the model at the same time
there's some tremendously good support
for
server side batching in in pi torch in
tertserv
i'll run through a slide uh in a bit
where i will show you the configurations
it abstracts most of the effort required
by the developer out so it requires
minimal to know if effort on the
developer's part to uh to write logic
for this batching uh
piece
uh you just need to provide the batching
size and the batch delay parameters in
the computer configuration files and
then torso takes care of the rest
and it has some really good support for
pre and post processing as well
so torso has custom hooks and custom
handlers
which are required to be overridden and
any special logic
for pre and post processing can be added
in those hooks and then again towards
opex it up uh
on the fly
so how to model a how to package mr or
how to package a model
um a model file is is packaged a model
is packaged into a mr file uh
using a torch model archiver which is a
utility given to us by the pytorch team
um
it bundles up all the dependencies all
configurations all uh
all the files required to run the model
at runtime in a single artifact and then
this artifact is then loaded into the
torch server so you can see the
you can see the the command required to
uh
to bundle up the the model files uh very
straightforward we'll be running through
a small demo during the hands-on in a
bit
um so i'll touch briefly upon how we are
we're making use of this handler at
walmart so since uh uh multiple teams
need to host their models on on torch
serve and then uh for the year further
take advantage of the cuda capabilities
uh what we have done is we have used we
have made a custom handler which extends
the base handler that pytorch provides
uh now any it acts as a as a top layer
on top of the base handler so any common
initialization any common pre-processing
error handling metric collection any of
these steps that are required
that are common across a lot of model
hosting
teams
these are abstracted out of the
developers and we take care of this um
so again you know the the point is uh to
minimize the effort required to host
models and then uh to hasten up the
process
so it gets very easy for developers to
host models uh on the fly uh any model
specific logic that the developer needs
to add will then be added in these
custom hooks these are the hooks i was
talking about so pre-process influence
and post process uh any pre-processing
logic any tokenization gets in here
inference logic uh your models are being
called inside the influencers and the
post process as as is
self-explanatory um
so it's a it's a resilient wrapper that
can be extended and used by multiple
teams uh across across the company
without the need for each team to uh to
set up some a similar handler for their
use cases
um so pytorch also has support for these
handlers uh so the use cases are image
classifying image segmentation object
detector text classifier um it's again
fairly straightforward just provide the
model file and then a json file and uh
whiteout takes care of it
uh so this is what the configuration
file looks like uh for for tort serving
um just provide the inference management
and the metrics addresses so here we
have configured the ports to be at zero
eight zero eight zero eight one and
eight through eight two which is i think
what usually is used
um number of
uh you can
you can configure the thread pool size
uh you can configure the matching uh
configurations here which is what i was
talking about earlier on so batch size
20 batch of delay um so very very
straightforward again no code changes
required uh
and also fix it up
so there's a management address there's
an inference address and there's a
there's a
metrics address
for the for the influence address that's
where you run your inference for the
management address
torcher provides
an api for us to to
scale out torque workers on the back end
for a cpu based environment the number
of cores on the cpu is what the num is
is set as the number of torch workers on
the back end for gpu based environment
this can be
configured
so here's an example for the management
api uh just get the details
uh with these apis
so we'll jump into another hands-on
session here we will talk about
how to package the model smart and then
run some live influencing
uh so again going back to the notebook
that nathan was sharing uh if you go to
the fourth notebook um i'll just show
you what the
model files look like what the working
directory is
um so here you have all your model store
model the models uh the model is hosted
inside the model store the tokenizer
files uh vocab files uh they're all part
of the mar bundle
uh now the torch model archival
just trying to help and you'll be able
to see
all the all the flags that are provided
along with the cli
so let's run this
so it's going to load the handler that
takes a bit of time
[Music]
two
[Music]
okay so we will not be able to see the
logs here right now but we've started
the torch server now
let's tail the logs
and
[Music]
okay so these are all the log files that
are available to us at runtime uh so the
metrics go inside the model metrics
access logs and the access logs
ds transfer whatsapp all the dots of
metrics going here
let's do it again okay there we go the
work has started
uh so let's see the configuration file
what it looks like so all the models
that are loaded inside the model store
uh will be loaded you can selectively
white list or blacklist some models as
well
um again influence address running at
9080 management one and metrics at eight
two
um
let's see
so this api provides to us this
management api call
provides to us all the models that are
loaded currently
on the torch server
so right now we have the prototype
classifier as the only model that's
running
if we append the name of the model to
this api we should be able to see the
number of workers that are loaded so
right now you can see there are two
torch workers running
uh batching configurations everything is
here all read from the picked up from
the configuration file
let's run a sample prediction on the
inference api
there we go so we've used
verbal t as a query and then we see that
it's classified
the query into into product types along
with their confidence course
that's uh that's about it you should be
able to run the live inference um on
this on the server if you if you have
the notebook running
uh
[Music]
that brings us back to the presentation
the lessons that we learned so we we
used uh a digital version of the
birthplace model along with quantization
and other optimizations and this is i'm
talking in context of the search team at
walmart and uh
we sort this on on a cpu
and uh
our latencies were below 40 m uh
milliseconds again below our sla
requirements but when we run this on a
gpu based environment the gpu here used
was an nvidia t4 tesla gpu uh at peak
traffic we were seeing under 10
milliseconds of latencies uh along with
a throughput of about 1500 1200 to 1500
requests per second um again well below
our sla uh we're targeting our
peak traffic daily usage and and holiday
usage as well um so here's a chart this
is where we're showing our influence
latencies you can see everything is
below in fact seven milliseconds is not
even ten or
nine okay i'll open the floor for any q
a now um
please check out walmart global tech for
openings for software engineers machine
learning engineers or data scientists
we're always hiring
um
yeah
by the way i saw a question in the
comments that said
whether quantization affects
um the the training time yes
quantization does bring up the training
time
um but then
you're you're improving drastically on
the influence times as well
um thanks a lot for joining the call and
have a nice
friday have a nice weekend ahead
you